Who wants to talk about science fiction? Anyway, shall we talk about the Hugo Finalists?
We want to talk about science fiction, John.
Hello everyone, welcome to episode 6 of the Octothorpe podcast,
a podcast about science fiction and SF fandom. I'm John Coxon.
I'm Alison Scott.
And I'm Liz Batty.
And we have a letter of comment from Espania Sheriff, my wife,
who attended a one-day convention called Wi-Fi Sci-Fi, which was hosted by Anne Collette,
and it was a mini-con consisting of a single Zoom panel in two parts,
followed by breakout room cavi-clatches. The panel had the topic SF and the pandemic,
tackled by five panelists, and then the second half of the panel was on the same topic,
but with different panelists. And then afterwards, you were assigned randomly to a breakout room with
one of the panelists. And in Espania's case, she talked to Corrie L. Lee, who was charming,
and then suddenly switched out to Adrian J. Walker, who was also lots of fun.
This is the second Wi-Fi Sci-Fi event that has been run, and you can find more details at
annecollettes.co.uk slash Wi-Fi Sci-Fi. I did not go, but I heard Espania having a lot of fun.
I believe I was playing board games on the internet while that was happening.
Is that because you are playing board games on the internet roughly 50% of the time you are awake, Tom?
No, that is a vicious lie. At least 25% of the time that I am awake, I am playing them in real life.
So there you go.
I think this is the second Wi-Fi Sci-Fi event, isn't it?
Yes. Clearly the first one went well if they've done a second one, and it seems like a kind of
nice way to spend three hours on a Saturday afternoon.
And it sounds like they've got the social aspects down a bit by just like randomly allocating you to
a room and you have a chat, which is, yeah.
Yeah, I am wondering whether this kind of mini convention will turn out to be a really viable
way of doing programming in the kind of current virtual age, because it means you can really
pick and choose what panels you want to go to. If like three people a weekend run a panel with
some socializing afterwards, you can massively split the amount of effort between a lot of
different people. You don't have to have a centralized effort, and you can pick and choose what events
you want to go to, which is potentially very cool.
I've done a lot of Zoom parties now, and I'm coming to the conclusion that for kind of just
having a good time, a number at around 30 to 40 is, well, maybe probably less than that, say invite 30
so that 25 or 20 turn up is really quite good, because that's enough for three different solid
conversations, which is all anyone's really going to get into anyway. And when you have more people,
you just up the level of complexity of keeping everyone organized, and it doesn't necessarily
do any better for people. So larger meetings aren't necessarily better. The advantage of great big
conventions or great big gatherings generally is that more of the people you want to see will be there,
but you can actually set up a virtual event with just the people you want to see on a particular topic.
I think for Zoom parties, it's also not quite the size of the room, but the people in the room. You need a certain amount of people in the room who are reasonably happy to sit there and chat on Zoom.
And you probably have some people who are sitting and chatting a little bit, but mostly sort of happy to listen. Like you need to replicate the dynamics of the conversation in the Zoom. If you have a quite full Zoom room, but no one kind of knows each other well, and they're not actually chatting, then that's not going to work either.
So the Wi-Fi sci-fi approach of having, all right, the author is in this room, and you can chat to the author, gives a sort of focus to them in a way that a general Zoom room party does not.
I have just realised that I have never personally had the experience of being in a Zoom room and having nobody in the room being willing to chat.
I didn't want to name names.
It may be that not everyone's experience is equivalent.
Because I have like, however much endless management training from years and years and years being tried to become a corporate clone and failing, I know I never find it difficult to start conversations in empty rooms.
It's also true that you will never be in the, you know, when you have Zoom parties and put people into breakout rooms, you are never in the room you are not in.
Yes.
If that makes sense.
Like, you never know what's going on in the other room.
So you probably assume that all rooms are kind of chatting away happily.
Whereas I have been in Zoom breakout rooms, which are a little bit quieter.
And you're sort of waiting for someone to get things going.
The problem, the problem with a Zoom party, I think, no, actually, the problem with a party is when you invite all of your friends and you're the only person that everyone knows.
And so that means that you get the clicks.
And if you've got like a couple of people who you're great mates with, but don't really know the rest of your friends at all, they're going to find it very difficult to interact.
And that's true at any party.
But I think it's also true in Zoom parties where if you've got a group of people, all of whom don't really know each other and only really know the host and the host is in a different breakout room, that will obviously be a problem.
OK, so my most recent Zoom party was credited as specifically a chance for European and Australian and New Zealand fans to get together at a time which was more or less convenient for both of them, but not convenient for Americans.
Because it had a structure, I think that helps somewhat with the thing.
And I kind of pretended that they were there to help me plan my guff trip, which they weren't.
They were just there to.
It was just to foster relations between European and Australian and New Zealand fans, which I think it did, though we didn't actually get any New Zealand fans except for Ming and Smitty, who don't count.
For those who don't know, Ming and Smitty both used to live in the UK before emigrating to New Zealand.
And so counting them as New Zealand fans is obviously fine, but may not be the New Zealand fans you're trying to reach out to in this particular case.
I will also say on the topic of Australian and New Zealand fandom, we were recommended by Claire Briley a podcast called the Two Chairs Talking Podcast, which is hosted by David Grigg and Perry Middlemiss, who are ex-chairs of previous Australian Worldcons.
And I gave that a listen in between last episode and this episode, and it's quite good.
They talk about books.
If you like Australian people talking about books, you may also enjoy it.
So give it a look.
Yes.
And they also, I think, record on a fortnightly schedule, as we do, and they have quite a lot, 27 episodes so far.
So they're a bit ahead of us.
On the topic of things that have happened in recent times, the Hugo finalists came out.
We touched on this in a previous episode, but we haven't really talked about it in any great detail.
So we're going to talk a little bit about that today.
And also, the BSFA awards were announced in a glittering ceremony on Zoom.
I think three hours late because they timed their awards ceremony to coincide with Zoom's first major outage since the start of lockdown, which is a tiny bit unfortunate, but I think they recovered quite well.
Oh, that's unfortunate.
Did you actually virtually attend?
I did not because of the whole middle of the night issue.
I did not.
I did not because of the whole not being a member of the BSFA issue, which I become, I'm feeling increasingly embarrassed about, actually, because one of the things I have been doing in lockdown is that they've been running author readings to compensate for not being able to do their regular pub meetings on a Wednesday in the middle of the month.
And I've gone to a couple of these and they've been jolly good.
So it turns out that author readings are one of the things I quite like in lockdown.
I like to be able to put on an author reading while I'm working with my hands.
Which is also good because when I was more involved in the BSFA, one of the things people would generally say is the London meetings are great, but I live outside London and can't get to them.
And so in lockdown, if they're now doing things broadcast by Zoom, again, they can have a slightly wider audience.
Yeah, I think I say Zoom there, but I think it's actually Facebook Live.
So now they will only get criticisms from people who are outside London and hate Facebook.
It's the BSFA Vector Reading Series.
And we should probably put a link in the show notes.
We shall do that.
So the BSFA Awards this year are great.
All of them, I think.
The winner of the best novel was Children of Ruin by Adrian Tchaikovsky.
Best short of fiction.
This is How You Lose the Time War by Amal El-Matar and Max Gladstone.
Best nonfiction was The Pleasant Professor of Robert A. Heinlein, Farah Mendelssohn.
And best artwork was the cover for Warism and Other Stories by Ian Waits, by Chris Baker, who's obviously better known as Fangorn.
Yeah, and they streamed it on Zoom, as we mentioned.
It seemed to go well.
I saw people talking about it on Twitter.
I must admit, I didn't watch because I am also not a member of the BSFA.
Although I am on the BSFA Discord.
So, you know, maybe I should join up.
And it does seem like they're doing some cool stuff at the moment.
I should probably be on the BSFA Discord, for that matter.
That sounds like good people doing good things on it.
I think they need to plug it slightly more because I think at the moment it is rather quiet.
I get the impression they're using it for their committee meetings.
So I think it is being used internally by the BSFA and is therefore at least somewhat active.
We shall put a link in the show notes.
Sorry, yes, I have read most of Tharra's book, which I found pretty interesting.
People keep thinking it's a biography, which it's not.
It's a close reading.
So it's probably of most interest to people who have read all of Heinlein's books, but quite a long time ago,
because I think actually Tharra coming to it with a fresh eye here in the 21st century is quite interesting.
I have read only This Is How You Lose a Time War,
which I definitely enjoyed.
But I think I enjoyed it, but it didn't kind of speak to me in my heart the way it has to a lot of people.
I know it is one of those books that comes along occasionally and a lot of people really, really love it.
And I merely liked it and really enjoyed it and admired it and think it's quite well done.
I will read This Is How You Lose the Time War because it is on the Hugo finalists this year.
So I will be reading it as part of my Hugo reading.
I will read Children of Ruin because I read the previous book in that series,
which I thoroughly enjoyed after a colleague in my research group recommended it,
which was called Children of Time.
And that was that was an amazing read.
So I do really want to read Children of Ruin, but I haven't got around to it yet.
But I have been reading the Hugo finalists.
I've made a start on chewing through some of those.
And I've also obviously kind of watched and read various bits of the Hugo finalists over the last year when they were actually coming out.
And so we're going to talk a little bit about what on the ballot that we have read, what we're planning to read,
what we enjoyed and what we didn't enjoy out of the stuff we know about.
And so the thing we're probably the most well up to date with is the best dramatic presentation categories,
which I think the three of us have watched most of.
So should we start with long form?
Yeah, I've seen everything on BDP long form apart from Star Wars, which I did mean to go and see.
But it came out at the point when I was about to go off on a long holiday back in the times when I was allowed to get on planes for a long period of time.
And the reviews came out and everyone said, oh, it's fine.
Oh, it's all right.
Oh, it's not that great, really.
And I thought, fine, I'll just go and see it later.
And then I never got around to it.
So I haven't seen it.
I understand it's fine to bad.
I really liked it.
It made me laugh and grin and clap and do all of those things.
I can entirely understand why people might not have liked it.
I think it is not a well-made movie, but it is a fun movie.
And I thoroughly enjoyed myself when I watched it.
I enjoyed it more than I enjoyed Endgame.
And that might be controversial.
Endgame's plot fundamentally made no sense to me.
And no one else seems to have this problem,
which is weird given the number of people that had a problem that Last Jedi had a hyperspace
jump in it.
But like, I don't know, the time travel in Endgame was just nonsense.
And I don't, I liked it.
It was fun.
It was a good ride.
Time travel is nonsense in all films apart from Looper, basically.
So I just...
Whoa, 12 monkeys?
Sorry, yes.
I did mean Prime and not Looper.
Time travel in the first Terminator movie holds up very well.
It's just that Terminator 2 went back and ruined it.
Shall I go back and do...
Sorry, so I could...
No, we're not going to let you undo your mistakes, Liz.
This is all going straight in.
I have the same reaction every time I see a J.J. Abrams film, which is that I leave the cinema
going, I thoroughly enjoyed that.
He did justice to the franchise that he is working in.
And then over the next few hours or days or weeks, the critical part of my brain goes,
well, did he really...
All he has done is parrot and ape bits of it without adding to or extending them in a way that is clever or interesting.
He just serves up fan service that is the cinematic equivalent of a shoe bun.
And I'm not saying I don't like shoe buns, but I feel that this was the culmination of a series
that I've been watching since I was 12 years old.
And we deserved a little bit more than that, especially given that the second episode had
done quite a lot to say we are taking this in a direction that isn't just giving adolescent
men in America what they want.
So I've got two reactions to that, which is firstly, I think that take on the two Abrams'
Star Wars movies fundamentally ignores one of their greatest strengths, which is I think the
characterisation in both of them is the best characterisation in any of the Star Wars movies.
I especially think that's clear in the first act of Rise of Skywalker, where the interaction between Rey and Poe and Finn
does an awful lot to tell you how much time has passed and how much they've gone through in between
Last Jedi and Rise of Skywalker in a way that doesn't need to be written down because it's all there in the direction and the acting.
And I actually think Abrams is the best director that has ever directed a Star Wars movie, which may be controversial.
And I think Last Jedi was fantastic.
I do enjoy Last Jedi.
I do wish that they hadn't decided to fundamentally reanalyse what it is to be Star Wars in the eighth part of a nine part series,
because I think that made it very difficult to tell a coherent story.
I think if the eighth part of your series is suddenly like, but now what about something completely different?
There are problems there.
And I think the other half of what's wrong with Rise of Skywalker is that it is very difficult to work out how you get from the end of The Last Jedi
to the end of the nine part saga in a way that's anything approaching narratively satisfying.
I do think that Rise of Skywalker has some absolute bobbins in it.
And it reminds me a little bit of some of the Russell T. Davis work on Doctor Who, where you've got the bit at the end.
Spoilers for those who haven't seen Rise of Skywalker.
But there's a bit at the end.
Liz, do you mind if I spoil Rise of Skywalker?
No, go for it.
Go for it.
There's a bit at the end where the Emperor basically uses force lightning on an entire solar system.
And it's a bit like, did we need that?
No.
If we did need that, did we need a little bit of text that explained why that was OK?
Probably.
I didn't mind it.
It wasn't great.
But Abrams does this.
He does the infinitely ratcheting up the stakes, which does cheapen the stakes in the earlier movies, which is a shame.
But generally speaking, I thought it had flaws, but I did generally really enjoy it.
I still think the best of the three sequel movies is The Force Awakens, which I thought in many ways was almost perfect.
And I thoroughly enjoyed.
But that is my take.
Can we agree that you should not give the Hugo to it?
I would suggest at the end of this segment, we decide who we should give the Hugo to.
I have ideas.
Neither of them are Rise of Skywalker.
So I am not arguing that it should be the Hugo Victor.
Ha ha!
The Hugo Victor.
Victor Hugo.
It was a pun.
I have not seen the two episodes of the Marvel Cinematic Universe extruded product because it is getting very large and life is too short.
Actually, you only need to watch two movies and two television series a year or something and you're all right.
But that.
I genuinely enjoy the MCU.
I enjoyed Captain Marvel, although in a way it was like, OK, this is maybe the 10th or 12th superhero origin story in the MCU I have seen.
And the exciting bit is now that they keep setting them in different random decades so they can have a different soundtrack and you can go, oh, it's got some 90s things in.
But I did.
I did still enjoy it.
I would probably go and watch another one.
I was thoroughly entertained for two and a half hours or whatever it is.
And it is nice to see a female lead.
Yes.
Brie Larson is someone I really like.
And so I liked her in it.
I will say, so I think I think Alison's point about it being the extruded Marvel Cinematic product, which is a very evocative metaphor, which I love.
I think it's true.
And I think it's difficult because I think one of the really shining things the MCU has done and whether or not you like the way it's done it, it's really interesting that they've taken a story and told it over a series of 20 movies with ancillary material.
Because I don't think that's really ever been done before.
And the closest you've probably got is James Bond, but that doesn't tell anything near a single story.
And so I think I think in some ways the MCU is actually really revolutionary in a way that people aren't really talking about.
But I think part of that is because it is really revolutionary telling a story where a lot of the beats are repeated.
And I can definitely see why there are people who are getting to the point where they're like, this is a bit I have gotten to the end of my patience with this.
Compared with most people I know, I have very low tolerance for the same story being told over and over with bigger bits over series.
From television series as well, I also struggle with this.
And we will get to why I think the two short television series are my favourite things of what I have so far seen.
I thought Good Omens was rather good.
I wasn't particularly expecting it.
I mean, I kind of knew it was in production.
I think that they did it in a way that did not overstay its welcome.
I think that the fact that Gaiman was on board probably helped sharpen the script to match modern sensibilities because Good Omens is 30 years old now.
And there are there is a lot of subtext in that novel that is not made anything like as clear as it was made in the series.
I thought a lot of ways that they used animation and time travel and all of that sort of thing were very clever and I thoroughly enjoyed it.
And of the ones I've seen on this list, which, as you know, is not very many, it's my second best.
I also enjoyed Good Omens.
I think I first read Good Omens when I was 10 or 11 years old and I loved it.
And it remains, you know, a book I have reread many times over the years and still really enjoy.
And while I like the TV adaptation, it is almost too faithful to the books.
It felt to me like there was too much trying to keep a lot of the actual wording of the books in by having some pretty unnecessary narration.
Narration from God.
And some of the bits they kept in, I think you could have cut entirely.
And also, I think some of the bits with, yes, I think some of the stuff with Sergeant Shadwell and Madam Tracy has not aged particularly well.
And it's really noticeable in the show, minor spoiler, the bit where Aziraphale sort of takes over Madam Tracy's body.
Works much, much better in the books because in the TV show, it just puts Michael Sheen out of action for an episode.
So I would really have liked to actually, if they trimmed it more, maybe trimmed out some of the bikers of the apocalypse, trimmed out these bits that I think don't work as well on screen.
And it was almost too faithful.
But it was way, way better than what I feared we might get.
So I can't complain too much.
So I will say, I think I agree with you.
I think it was too faithful.
I think they should have taken more liberties with it.
And I am also in the same boat that I think I read Good Omens when I was 10 or 11.
And it remains a very, very fond memory.
It was the book that introduced me to both Pratchett and Gaiman's writing.
So it will always have a place in my heart.
I think I agree with you that they needed to do more to make it into a TV show rather than into a TV version of a book.
I will say that I thought the chemistry between most of the characters was amazing.
And I thought the actors did a tremendous job.
I am happy that Michael Sheen and David Tennant are getting a lockdown TV show together.
As far as I can tell off the back of the fact that they were good together in Good Omens, which is Chef's Kiss.
I thought Jack Whitehall was very good, which surprised me because I was expecting not to think he was very good.
The thing you said about the Bikers of the Apocalypse is really interesting because my main problem with that is that they cut out all of the funny bits and left in all of the other bits.
And I think they really needed to decide whether they were going to keep the hilarious other four bikers, which made it work, or whether they were going to really slim down that whole thing.
But they sort of went for a middle road where they took the funny bit out.
And that I'm not sure.
And I do wonder whether that's because it was Neil Gaiman that was overseeing the adaptation and not Terry Pratchett.
Because I wonder whether some of the more out there funny bits of Good Omens were more on Pratchett's side than Gaiman's, shall we say.
But generally speaking, I thought it was very good.
I'm not sure it's my favourite of the roster, but I really liked it.
Gaiman is very good at whimsy, but he is not a humorist in the way that Pratchett was.
And very little of Gaiman's solo output is laugh out loud hilarious.
So I think you can reasonably assume that everything properly funny in Good Omens comes from Pratchett.
Everything that's properly funny and I think properly sort of sharp humor as well seems to me to be more of a Pratchett thing than a Gaiman thing.
I mean, obviously, this is all speculation and we may be entirely wrong, but it seems reasonable from what we know about the two authors.
With a bit of luck, we'll get a lock from Neil Gaiman telling us how we're going.
Yes, Neil, please write in and tell us how we've gotten all this wrong.
We would love to hear from you.
I really like Russian Doll.
I like lots of things it did.
And I like the fact that just I think I hadn't noticed when it came out that Netflix was in the habit of just sticking up some stuff that was quite out there.
And I like that Russian Doll is I don't think it's like hugely original, but I like the fact it was clearly quite cheap to make.
And so therefore it doesn't have when you read novels and they're great and interesting and weird.
You think, well, if this had been made into a film or a television series, people would have shaved bits off the edges to make them fit more tightly into a mold of what they think extruded cinematic product should be like.
And Russian Doll absolutely doesn't do that.
It's got a load of characters and they're quite wild and they do a load of things.
You know, a harrowing is actually spectacularly not particularly nice in a way that is not that common, even in the more elaborately varied television that we get now.
And it's short.
So they made quite a short amount of it and it tells a whole story and then it's done.
And I don't know if they're planning to do any more.
Obviously, when things are a big success on Netflix, they tend to do a second series.
That's a little bit of a shame.
But it feels like it told a whole story and it was done and it had lots of proper science fictional content, which even now, even with all the science fiction around us all the time, we don't get as much of that as we maybe should.
And I thought it was funny and entertaining.
And that's what I want from my long form dramatic presentation.
Thank you very much.
And don't necessarily get it, though.
It's kind of eight short form dramatic presentations.
So it once again demonstrated that the Hugo categories are very complicated.
I think I would say that it feels like something which fits much better in long form than many series which have been nominated in long form, because I think it does tell one complete story over eight episodes.
And that's one reason why it's so satisfying to watch.
Without spoiling it, it is not a concept that is entirely new.
I did think that it is quite innovative in that it is a very dark comedy in a way that you don't often see US kind of situation comedies do.
And the bleakness of it and the humour of it was really refreshing.
I really liked that.
I think it's relatively unusual for comedy to be taken seriously.
It's relatively unusual for genre to be taken seriously.
So the fact that this was a genre comedy that was taken seriously was really pleasing.
And I think stands in opposition to The Good Place, which is another genre comedy that was taken seriously, but has a very different feel in terms of its optimism to Russian Doll.
And so I'm really happy that Russian Doll is on the roster.
And I think it's one of the two that I would be the happiest to see win.
And what is the other one, John?
The other one I would be happy to see win is US, directed by Jordan Peele.
I have not seen US, but I do want to.
And I suspect it's quite good just because everything Jordan Peele has ever done is good.
So we will not be spoiling so that Alison does not have to put her fingers in her ears and shout la la la, because I do not want to have to edit around that.
So, Liz, can you spoiler free discuss what you liked about US?
I think what might be funnier is if I did it with spoilers and elaborate hand gestures and Alison had to put it on mute and just watch me, you know, mime the entire film.
But that would probably not be much fun for the listeners.
I will not be doing that.
Alison, you can put them back in.
I feel that would be too boring for the listeners.
I think the best part about us was when the Hoff turned up.
No.
I liked it.
I don't watch a lot of horror films, but I did find this one to be scary, but in a really sort of plot and character driven way, if that makes sense.
Like it felt like a slasher film, but with something really deep going on under it.
I think that acting is fantastic.
I don't think it's really spoiling anything because it's in the trailer to say that there are lots of doppelgangers involved.
And I think all the acting of the people with their doppelgangers is amazing.
You can always tell who is who, even if they're not speaking.
The acting in it is phenomenal and the direction is phenomenal.
But I also think it is creepy in a way that I find most horror movies are not.
But I think both Us and Get Out are incredibly creepy movies that made me feel really uncomfortable in a really nice way.
That's going to sound weird, but like I enjoyed the feeling of uncomfort I had while I was watching them.
They really got under my skin and I really enjoyed them.
I think Us is really, really great.
And I think you can see that Jordan Peele's background in comedy is helping a lot with his ability to do the timing.
I think his sense of comic timing is helping him a lot with the pacing and the way he can make you feel uncomfortable through the film.
I really liked it.
I would be very happy to see it win.
I would highly recommend watching it.
Me and Espania bought Us and Get Out on iTunes for 15 quid because they've got a bundle at the moment.
We thoroughly enjoyed watching Us the other week.
So what do you feel should win based on the ones you've seen anyway?
Of the ones I've seen, I'd be voting for Russian Doll.
For all the reasons about things not overstaying their welcome and telling a story in the right amount of space that I've seen.
But I mean, I'm sure that Us is well up there as well.
And I also like Good Omens.
Do you want to rank them in order, Alison?
Like, as you would on your ballot?
Of the ones I've seen, I've only seen three of these, haven't I?
She has ranked the three she's seen, I think.
Which are Russian Doll, Good Omens.
Rise of Skywalker.
Sorry, I should say more clearly.
Russian Doll, Good Omens.
Noah Ward, Rise of Skywalker.
Fair, fair.
What will you be ranking them, Liz?
You've put me on the spot now because I hadn't thought about my lower ranked choice voting.
I think number one is Us.
Probably Russian Doll.
I'm going to have to think about it some more.
There's things I love about Good Omens and Captain Marvel and Avengers Endgame.
But I really need to think about it some more.
And how much of it is, am I judging Avengers Endgame as a film?
Or am I judging Avengers Endgame of the 20th in a series of 20 films?
I think this is actually a really interesting question.
Because I kind of wish that the Marvel Cinematic Universe had been nominated as a single dramatic presentation long for.
Like the whole thing from Iron Man to Endgame.
Because if that happened, I would have ranked it one.
But as it is, I'm going to put Russian Doll.
Then I'm going to put Us.
Then I'm going to put Good Omens.
Then I'm going to put Captain Marvel.
Then I'm going to put Rise of Skywalker.
And then I'm going to put Endgame.
Because I fundamentally didn't feel like Endgame did a good job of wrapping up the MCU.
I think a lot of people liked it because it had a lot of fan service in it.
But I just didn't think it held together as a movie very well at all.
But I did enjoy seeing it in the cinema.
And there are some really good bits.
I enjoyed all of them is the problem.
I wouldn't put any of them below no award.
We may get on to discussions of when you would put something below no award.
But this is not the category where I would.
Yes, okay.
I'm probably being a bit harsh.
I just would be so sad if we got to Virtual Con Zealand and they gave the Hugo to Rise of Skywalker.
And I do think it's a very significant risk because I think there are a lot of people at the World Con
who've been watching Star Wars movies for 40 years and would like to see an award for that.
I think that's a good point because I think if Star Wars and Endgame are going to get ranked on the entirety of the sagas they belong to instead of as individual works,
it becomes much harder to predict what the fandom is going to give the Hugo to.
So I think if people don't do that, it will go to either Russian Doll or us.
I think if they do do that, then Endgame's got a really good chance of winning, is my thought.
Although Good Omens has a lot of fans, so maybe I'm wrong.
Maybe Good Omens could steal it.
I wouldn't want to bet money.
Oh, Good Omens really does have a lot of fans.
It really does.
Okay, so we were going to discuss best dramatic presentation short form, but it turns out we had a lot of thoughts.
And so we're going to leave that for a future episode.
Do we want to touch on staying sane in the apocalypse?
My method of staying sane in the apocalypse is having discussions with you two about the minutiae of Disney-based marketing schedules.
How are you both coping with COVID-19?
I do find that making sure that I'm having chats with my friends, and not only that,
that I'm making sure that those chats go in different directions,
so that I'm talking to different friends about different things on different occasions,
is really important for me.
And that I do set up Zoom chats where unexpected people are talking to each other,
because I think you get...
If you're always talking to the same people,
even if you frame it around a board game,
or a quiz night,
or whatever,
you inevitably get to the point where somebody goes,
have you been anywhere nice recently?
And the other person goes,
well, I went for a nice walk in Bluebell Woods at Castle Barnard.
And then you realise that there's only so much you can say about walking in Bluebell Woods.
It's not true.
But you actually run out very quickly of things to talk about,
even though we've all been watching things and doing things.
Whereas if you actually get some different people together,
you can actually start to have the meaty conversations about,
you know, everything else in the world.
Because people from different countries and people in different situations do have different experiences,
and they're good.
I think I've been doing much the same.
Have you been talking to a plethora of people, Liz?
I mean, I have, but that's because I also went out and had socially distanced outdoor coffee with some people yesterday,
because we are on a much freer schedule, I think, than you guys are at this point.
Caroline came round and had a coffee at my house,
and I did not think we had broken any rules, but it turns out that we did.
She came to my house and put six Georgettea novels on my doorstep,
whilst in the process of doing other errands which are legal.
And then she went and sat in my front garden, some distance away from the house.
And I came out with a polypin of beer, which I was selling her,
and put it on my recycling bin.
And then we had a cup of coffee together at about three metres apart,
which I thought was completely legal and fine now.
But it turns out we needed to actually walk into the street,
because you could only do it at this in an outdoor public place.
So if we'd had done exactly the same thing,
but I'd started off by putting two chairs in the middle of the road,
we'd have been good.
Fair enough.
But as it was, it was legal.
It was great fun, though.
I've got to the stage where every time you see another human being,
you're like, oh, this is amazing.
It's a person.
We can drink coffee.
We can have a conversation.
Yeah, we have in our garden, we have a fence which is short enough
that if we sit in the middle of our garden
and our neighbours sit in the middle of their garden,
we can shout at each other while having lunch.
And that is quite good for conversation.
It does need you to shout.
You can't talk normally.
But it works quite well, actually.
We're probably about three or four metres apart, I would say.
But yeah, it's not bad.
And then I've also been having Spanish lessons from my sister-in-law,
which has been fun.
It keeps you occupied.
And I really, really hate talking in Spanish.
Not because I don't like Spanish,
but because, as listeners will have noted,
I talk quite a lot.
And talking and being unable to say the thing you want to say
is a very frustrating thing.
I think if you talk a lot, I'm finding it really difficult.
But I am persevering.
And it is quite good so far.
This is why extroverts struggle with language learning.
Because, you know, you have all these things to say
and it's incredibly hard to say them.
And then you do language learning.
And I've got to the stage where I can read quite a lot of Japanese now,
but cannot say anything in Japanese.
And that's it.
And that's really embarrassing.
You're learning Thai, Liz.
I am.
Yes, I'm having online language lessons.
And one of the problems is that
it can sometimes be quite hard to hear.
And one of the key things that we are
supposed to be learning right now
is how to read the different tones
from the different combinations of consonants and vowels.
And so what it actually leads to
is me saying something
and then doing a hand motion
to prove that I do know
what tone it's supposed to be in,
even if it's not possible to hear over Zoom
exactly what tone I'm using.
So there's a lot of like hands going up
and hands going down
and hands representing rising and falling tones.
It's quite funny.
Excellent.
And we can have a octothor
where I speak in Spanish,
Liz speaks in Thai
and Alison is the only one anyone can understand.
And that will be fun.
Absolutely.
Because you do need my hand gestures
to tell what tone I'm supposed to be attempting.
I can embed pictures of you doing them
in the podcast art.
So I don't know whether listeners have picked up on this,
but I put pictures in the podcast.
So if you're looking at your podcast player
when a certain part of the podcast plays,
the picture will change sometimes,
you know, if there's a relevant picture to the discussion.
And I could do second long chapters
with Liz gesturing to indicate where her tone should be.
And that would be a delightfully hacky way
of solving the problem, I think.
Thank you everyone for listening to the sixth episode
of the Octothorpe podcast.
We will see you in a four nights time.
But for now, I have been John Coxon
and it's goodbye from me.
And I have been Alison Scott
And I have been and still am Liz Batty
and it's goodbye from me.
Yay!
Yay, that's six episodes.
That's amazing.
Are we eligible for Hugo yet?
The theme music for this episode was Fanfare for Space
by Kevin MacLeod and Compotech.com
used under a Creative Commons Attribution 3.0 license.
Okay.
So I think one of the really interesting things
about the MCU is that they're doing this kind of
two or three movie a year product
where they're doing movies which are
in some ways very similar to each other.
And then occasionally there's a movie
which is quite different.
Like for instance,
the first Guardians of the Galaxy felt quite different
or the Ant-Man films feel quite different.
But then other films feel quite similar.
And one of the really interesting things
is that they did try that with Star Wars.
They released Solo,
which was an attempt to do a heist movie
that felt different from the saga.
And it was relatively poorly received
by the fandom and financially.
And I think they have almost decided
to retreat from doing a lot of movies
into the realm of TV.
So they've announced
they're doing the Obi-Wan Kenobi TV series.
They're doing the Mandalorian.
They've brought the Clone Wars back.
I'm sure they've announced something else
that I'm forgetting.
But a lot of what they're doing in Star Wars
seems to be more on the television
slash book slash comic side.
And they seem to be really hesitant
to try and make a Star Wars cinematic universe.
And I think it's really interesting
the way that Marvel has been able
to tell this multi-movie story.
But when Star Wars tried something similar,
I think it was quite poorly received.
And I am wondering how that's going to impact
Lucasfilm and Marvel's decisions
going forward from here.
Because for whatever reason,
I think they're in quite different situations
with regards to their fan bases.
And I'm not entirely sure why.
Well, I think part of that is that
basically the film landscape
is just too crowded for Disney right now
because they have Marvel films.
They have Star Wars films.
They have Pixar.
They have Disney animation.
They have their live action remakes
of Disney animation.
And they're in a position
where if they're not careful,
they will start cannibalizing
their own audience.
But in a way,
I think it's also just that
Solo was highly anticipated
and not that great.
I think I would also cite Rogue One here,
which is also a chance to tell
a different sort of story
in the Star Wars cinematic universe.
And I think which worked
completely on its own terms
and was great.
So, you know,
I think there is still,
there is more they can do here.
I think,
I think I will push back a little bit
on Solo being hotly anticipated.
I, I, I, I'm quite,
it may surprise you to learn
I follow quite a few people
who are fans of Star Wars
on the Twitters.
But I didn't see a lot of excitement
for Solo.
And a lot of people I follow
were very skeptical
that it was a story
that needed to be told.
And I think part of the problem
with Solo is that it was a prequel.
And I think Star Wars fans
are very skeptical of prequels.
I can't think why.
But, and I think one of the really
interesting things as well
was that because it came out
five months after The Last Jedi,
The Last Jedi had only been out
of cinemas for about six weeks
when Solo was in cinemas.
I just wonder whether
they should have pushed it back
to the, because,
because they had been trying
to release all of these movies
at summer and they had all
been pushed back to Christmas.
And Solo was the first one
of the new Disney era
where they managed to release it
on time.
But I actually think releasing
it on time was a huge mistake
because it meant you didn't
have enough time to build up
that anticipation
in between The Last Jedi
and Solo.
It felt like The Last Jedi
had only just come out really.
And so I think,
I think there were a large number
of missteps made.
And I, but, and I agree
that I think,
and I don't know
whether I'm right.
I think the reaction to Solo
was much more because
of the lack of marketing
and the lack of thought
about when to release it
than it was about the quality
of the movie.
Because I think quality
is almost irrelevant
when it comes to blockbusters.
And that's not just Star Wars.
It's like, there's a very
pessimistic view of all movies.
Yeah, they had a very serious
not Harrison Ford problem too.
I watched the Star Wars movies
when I was very young
in like the 90s
and I am not as attached
to Harrison Ford
as my parents are
who were very appalled
that Harrison Ford
was not in it.
But I do wonder
whether that's the other part.
It's like a film
that's designed to appeal
to original trilogy fans,
but it's a film that
treads on the old trilogy's
toes in some ways.
Liz, did you have any?
I did have several things.
Can I say the several things
I was going to say?
Yes, say the several things.
So one thing I would push back
on that is Marvel released
Captain Marvel and Avengers
Endgame two months apart.
So I don't think there's a reason
you can't release these things
in quick succession
if you think the audience,
you know, obviously there is
an audience there
for some of them.
I mean, Avengers Endgame
is kind of a special case,
but it didn't seem to hurt
Captain Marvel.
People were not staying away
thinking, oh, I'll go
and see the next one
or I've just seen one.
And my main issue with Solo
is I don't think
Alden Ehrenreich does
a particularly great job
and I just found it to be
not that entertaining,
to be honest.
So just to push back on that,
Solo has a higher
Tomatometer score
than Rise of Skywalker
and a higher audience score
than Last Jedi.
So if we're going to say
it's about the quality
of the movies,
I would have thought
either Rise of Skywalker
or Last Jedi
should have been much worse
in terms of box office
than Solo.
and I appreciate
that the Marvel movies
have been much closer together
and I don't know why
I think the Marvel movies
don't have this problem,
but I definitely feel like
there was a large reaction
in the Star Wars fandom
which was
we don't need this movie
and a large lack
of anticipation
in a way that there isn't
for Marvel.
And so I agree
on the face of it,
I think it seems like
you should be able
to release Solo
five months after
Last Jedi.
It should be fine.
But I am just
deeply unconvinced
that I think it was
anything to do
with the quality of the movie.
Because like I say,
in some ways Solo
was better received
than Episode 8
and Episode 9
and it did far worse
than the box office.
Like far worse.
I miss what you were saying
about Last Jedi.
Were you saying about
what were you
rating Last Jedi by?
So if you look at
the Last Jedi
audience reviews,
Last Jedi got 90%
from critics
and got like 40%
from the audience.
Rise of Skywalker
got about 40%
from critics
and about 90%
from the audience
if I recall correctly
or it might have been
lower on the audience side.
And then Solo
got about 70%
on both.
And so if Solo
is worse
and that's why
it did worse,
then either Last Jedi
or Rise of Skywalker
should have done
even worse.
And the fact they didn't
I think is difficult
to explain.
I think there is
a quality-based explanation
which is that Marvel
at this point
is an extremely solid,
reliable brand
and they very rarely
drop films
people feel are duds.
So people are now
reassured that if they
go and see a Marvel film
it will probably meet
at least a particular
high-water mark
and probably go higher.
I don't think people
are convinced of that
for Star Wars films yet.
And I think there's also
the obvious problem
with looking at
The Last Jedi's
audience rankings
and that we know
The Last Jedi
is really not liked
in a particular
subset of fandom
who are probably
more likely to have
gone and written
reviews of it.
We may be going
too far into
Star Wars versus
Marvel.
I have one tiny
more thing to say
about Marvel
which is that
one of the reasons
I think that
Marvel,
the whole Marvel
cinematic universe
with all its
entrails and tendrils
is accepted
and even loved
for that
by its audience
is that it's
actually coming
from a source
which is its
comics which
because Stan Lee
invented
the system
of getting people
to buy more
product
in comics
by having
all of these
crossovers
this is what
this is
it's always
been doing
this.
it's the
thing that
is unique
about Marvel
and so
to some extent
they have just
encapsulated the
Marvel unique
selling point
which is they
don't just sell
you stuff
they sell you
a very large
amount of
stuff and
you like it.
That's actually
a really good
point.
I think
the fact that
Marvel has
source material
that is tried
and tested
may also
massively help
and I
it's very
but I think
I didn't
sorry I didn't
intend to
derail this
into the
discussion
it's become
but I just
I'm not
sure I'm
right but
I'm not
sure it's
obvious why
Star Wars
can't sustain
the same level
of movie
releases as
Marvel and
it could just
be that Solo
was empirically
bad but I
am sceptical
that that's the
whole story but
I don't know
and so that was
all I was trying
to
welcome to
Octothorpe
where this
week in the
absence of
new news
from science
fiction and
fandom we are
having a two
hour animated
discussion on
Star Wars
versus Marvel
it's definitely
on topic guys
I think you're
correct I don't
think it that
Solo is it's
not a bad
film I just
didn't enjoy it
that much but
I think had
Solo turned out
to be a
really really
good film like
a Guardians of
the Galaxy
level of quality
or something like
that then people
might have
gone ah they
can make good
films that are
entertaining in
between the
big trilogy films
oh I was not
expecting a close
reading of the
Marvel v Star Wars
that was not where
I thought this was
going
not sure it was
that close a
reading
fighting talk
let's fighting
talk
Johnny you know
definitely like
screen sharing
with us
deliberately
yes look at
this graph
oh I see
okay
this is the
lockdown spike
index published
per month on
arcumtv.com
which I thought
was interesting
because it just
rockets
what's the
graph
oh yes
I've been
you know how
people say you
should not
extrapolate from
your personal
experience to
to the world
in general
I've been
extrapolating from
the things my
Facebook friends
talk about
I have a fairly
diverse large
I mean they're all
middle class obviously
but I have a fairly
diverse large group
of Facebook friends
and I've been
extrapolating like
mad from my
Facebook friends
what they've been
doing and it seems
to work out
and I have now
noticed that it
also works on
gaming I think
people are gaming
about three times
as much as
they did before
lockdown
I guess but
the thing you
have to bear in
mind Alison is
that I am
responsible for
how many
arcum horror decks
have you made
John now how
many of those
that spike is
just you
coming up with
arcum horror decks
uh actually no
so okay so that
is actually a very
good question
I will count
it is not a
trivial question
shall we
finish the podcast
and then
and then get
onto the more
fun like post
podcast bit
yeah
oh no it's
just you is it
oh shit
sorry
sorry I had
not gathered
John is
responsible for
the global
spike in
arcum horror
decks
public
the after
show how
many so
yeah so
three times as
much gaming
I reckon
and that's
based on how
many of my
hearthstone
friends are
online at
any given
time
um
you